[Musique]
pourtant c'était le dernier jour d'école
avant les vacances mais personne ne
voulait manquer ce moment au théâtre
plein air un échauffement avant de
rejoindre daniel waro sur scène c'est un
moment magique en mai 2000 20 41
collégiens et dix sept encadrants seront
au népal c'est daniel hoareau et houssem
savannah oui oui en fait au départ je
pensais qu'on a n'est pas vraiment le
faire que c'était juste un projet que ça
allait nous passer mais en fait
finalement voilà on y va vraiment mais
on va les distribuer des lunettes
ils sont trop peu de soleil du coup et
oui il voit pas très bien
du coup et c'est pour ça qu'on récolte
des lunettes
je suis polie de nous là bas ça me
construis sam apprend justement avoir
des responsabilités pour plus tard moi
l'année prochaine je passe au lycée donc
voilà ça m'aide un peu ce projet qui
mobilise quatre établissements et initié
par cet homme discret à la rubalise le
chef d'orchestre de cette équipe
pédagogique qui s'engagent pour nous on
est là il ya une autre manière de
travail hors les murs et c'est vraiment
un espace d'épanouissement personnel et
professionnel c'est ce mélange là qui a
fait qu'il ya des enseignants j'ai du
mal à dire enseignants parce que c'est
des personnes habiter et qui se sont
investis dans le projet est donc c'est
vraiment un mélange de l'émotion et du
professionnel est en fait ça donne je
pense que ça permet un certain nombre de
collègues de retrouver du sens et du
lien entre leurs métiers leurs émotions
leur tempérament je crois que ça c'est
très très très important
[Musique]
patient et déterminé sur un projet
pourtant pluriannuel ses enfants pour
certains de classe à difficulté s'engage
et vivent ainsi un moment exceptionnel
et jean montech 25 et que c'est quelque
chose de très important et que ensuite
quand on a la chance de monter sur une
scène comme le tpa avec des artistes
comme ça ce sont des un moment ce sont
des moments qui resteront longtemps
[Applaudissements]
si nous avons là-bas avec un magnet a
foncé l'école formaté de cela mais ne
sera pas présente à réunion ne sont pas
présentes ni la musique ni la langue ni
rien ne dit que sinon ça va là bas avec
un magasin ou richie et son sillage en
créole
elle n'a plus sa chance à mouthe
vraiment une différence parce que c'est
ça c'est ça rend con la rencontre ces
rencontres bonne différence est sans
surprise près de 1200 spectateurs sont
venus applaudir ce projet une validation
social qui fait du bien à un an de cette
expédition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]